Mr Speaker the war in Ukraine is
entering a critical stage Freedom must
win out over tyranny and Putin's
aggression must fail
as the ukrainians continue to defend
themselves and prepare for an offensive
to push Putin's forces out it is crucial
they know the nations of the G7 continue
to support their fight without waiver
we will stand with them for as long as
it takes we will stand with them because
their decisive Victory is the route to a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace
therefore labor welcomes the strong show
of support for President zielinski we
welcome the decision by our partners on
F-16 fighter jets
we also welcome restrictions on exports
that Aid the Russian war machine and we
welcome the tightening of the Vice on
the mineral trade that is funding
Putin's aggression
I would urge the prime minister to
prescribe the Wagner group as terrorists
and to ensure Britain's sanctions are
not just in place but enforced no one
has been fined for breaching sanctions
since the War Began
Mr Speaker as I told president zielinski
when I met him in Kiev
whichever party is in power in the UK
there will be no let up in Britain
resolve we will continue to support
Ukraine's military and its people in
their Quest For Freedom for peace and
for justice and when their moment of
Victory comes we will be there to help
them rebuild from the rubble of War
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that when it comes to Ukraine it is
important that we continue to show that
we are united across this house
Mr Speaker I also welcome the commitment
to de-risk our economic relationship
with China
it is in our national interest to engage
they will be crucial Global Partners in
the effort to reach Net Zero and we have
a trading relationship worth a hundred
billion pounds
but that Pursuit should never come at
the cost of Economic Security
and we should never leave ourselves
vulnerable to economic coercion
we must be clear-eyed about the facts
China is increasingly aggressive in the
Pacific
they showed disdain for democratic
values and human rights and they are
seeking to exploit economic Leverage
a decade of ignoring these facts and
Tory governments closing up to Beijing
have gifted the Chinese Communist Party
a stake in Britain's key infrastructure
we need to change Tack and labor is
willing to work with the government on
this it is time for a full audit of UK
China relations and to work more
consistently with our allies to develop
a long-term plan for Western engagement
and a long-term plan for Economic
Security
because as this winter has shown us
in the modern world Economic Security is
National Security
as the world races to invest in new
technologies and to make their supply
chains more robust we must make sure
British businesses can take advantage
the Prime Minister has rightly pointed
out the importance of the semiconductor
industry
they are the brains of our electronic
devices indispensable components of
cutting-edge manufacturing
the US and the EU have big plans to grow
and nurture their sectors to remove any
vulnerabilities from their supply tones
now we've waited a long time for the UK
to present its strategy
it finally arrived last week
and an industry leader described it as
frankly flaccid
does that worry the Prime Minister as
much as it worries me
whilst others build resilience and seize
opportunities this government seems
content with managed decline
and this isn't the only area where I
fear we're being left behind
the US and the EU the US and the EU use
the G7 to continue important talks that
would allow European companies to share
in billions of dollars of U.S tax
incentives for electric vehicles and
green technologies and vice versa
last week we saw warnings about the
future of the UK car industry
people who work in the sector are very
worried
they want leadership
so could the Prime Minister confirm his
government will secure the same or
better access for British manufacturers
and when can we expect to hear progress
on this
when the influx when the inflation
reduction Act was passed the
government's response wasn't to outline
what opportunities this offered to
Britain
it was to say it was dangerous and to
suggest that an active industrial
strategy is somehow not the British way
wake up it's not the 1980s anymore a
race is on we need to be in it and we
need to win our share of the jobs of the
future we can't afford to be stuck in
the changing rooms complaining about how
unfair life is
Mr Speaker as the war in Europe
continues to rage Hiroshima was a
fitting stage for the G7 Summit a city
which has seen unimaginable Horrors has
risen from its past
it can serve as an inspiration for those
in Ukraine who fight daily for their
freedom their future couldn't be bright
from Ukraine to China to climate change
today's challenges are big but if we
stay United with our allies and partners
if we work together they are not
insurmountable and if we're focused if
we have a plan the economic
opportunities of the future are bigger
still Britain must seize them with both
hands and our future could be bright too